how's it going everybody it's Warren and
today is the day of vendors in games
official worldwide release I know there
are a couple of countries that got it a
few days ago I believe the Netherlands
and Australia got it yesterday but the
official worldwide release is today and
I'm super excited I see the movie in
just a few hours and before I go in I
want to talk about what I expect to
happen and see in a vengers endgame I
know a lot of you have been asking me
what I think is going to happen what I
predict will happen so just for fun just
messing around I'm gonna talk about what
I think is going to happen in the movie
if there are any spoilers in this video
it is not intentional I have not seen
the movie I have not looked at the
leaked footage and I am assuming that
basically a lot of what I say is going
to be incorrect just because I've heard
that this movie has a lot of things in
it that you don't expect to see so this
is purely me speculating and going off
what I know from the comics and what I
known from everything that we've got in
this past year so I believe the story is
going to start off making some sort of a
flashback to Avengers infinity war where
feyo's perform the snap and then I think
it's going to go to Tony and nebula and
I think they're going to do everything
they can to prepare the ship but
ultimately it won't be enough this leads
to Tony recording his message to pepper
saying that he's about to die and then
we go to the Avengers headquarters where
some of the remaining heroes are
regrouping I think agent Klein of shield
shows up and gives them Nick Fury's
pager and then of course we know that
Captain Marvel comes into the Avengers
headquarters because of the post-credits
scene for Captain Marvel they explained
to her who Thanos is and what he did and
that Nick Fury is now gone and I think
immediately or very soon after this they
actually receive Tony Stark's message
and then Captain Marvel goes into space
finds them and brings them back when
they get back Tony is still very hurt so
he goes to get medical attention with
pepper and then we go to the scene where
the Avengers have managed to track down
Thanos because he used the stones again
the team ultimately decides to go defeat
Thanos get the stones and use them to
snap everybody back to life and I think
everybody goes to fight Thanos with the
exception of Tony Stark and then I think
one of two things could happen the first
is something that I actually don't think
will be
the movie but I think it's a path that
they may have thought of going down and
that is the Infinity Gauntlet is
actually permanently damaged and doesn't
completely work anymore so they go they
find Thanos they fight him and they
actually defeat him
but before phantos dies he actually
laughs at them and this is something
that I've actually written fanfiction
about I believe that famous would say
something along the lines of and what
will you do now
now that you've defeated me Avengers do
you think you've saved your world your
universe the stones are destroyed you
can't undo my destiny killing me does
nothing it only sends me to my rest with
my love you have avenged nothing not
your world your home your universe your
fallen nothing you've failed and my
universe remains balanced so I think
Fanus would say something along those
lines and then he would die and the
Infinity Gauntlet would be damaged and
the stones could not bring everybody
back to life which is where ant-man
comes in a little bit down the road
The Avengers lose all hope until he
arrives and then they realize that they
can go back in time and collect the
stones from the past but as they do this
they end up changing the future and
Thanos comes back to life so that's one
way that I think they could have taken
the movie but I actually don't think
they're going to go that route what I
think we'll see is the Avengers go to
fight Thanos and fail he'll defeat them
maybe even without the Infinity Gauntlet
but before they're all killed Thor takes
them all back home with a Bifrost and
they realized that they're never going
to be able to get the Infinity Gauntlet
from Thanos so some of them give up and
some of them keep looking for a
different way to get the gauntlet from
Thanos and undo the snap but they come
up with nothing but then a little bit
later down the road ant-man shows up
from here ant-man
Tony Stark and Bruce Banner figure out
how to use the quantum realm to
time-travel
and this is where the Avengers will
begin to go back to different parts in
time the past and the future I believe
the Avengers will make their own
Infinity Gauntlet and I think it's going
to be either Thor or professor Hulk who
wields it those are the only two that I
can see being strong enough to wield it
on their own as they go back in time I
do think that there are certain events
that they have to let play out for
example the Battle of New York and
Avengers age of Ultron that way vision
Wanda and Quicksilver are still made
however I think they're going to find
the perfect points in time to take the
stones where the future is no longer
affected by them taking the stones so
they'll figure out these points and
that's where they'll get the Infinity
stones I do think that Thor will travel
back to neduvaali R and I do think that
Tony Stark is going to have a room metal
Iron Man suit I know we see the mark 85
suit but I do think that he's going to
get another one in Avengers in game I
also think Wong is going to be able to
communicate with Doctor Strange and the
ancient one and I do believe that the
Avengers are going to use the quantum
realm to go into soul world from here I
think they come up with a plan much like
the comics I think they'll wait for the
perfect time most likely a final battle
at the end of Avengers endgame and
Doctor Strange will bring all of the
Fallen Heroes back this is where we're
going to see all of the heroes together
in one scene taking on Thanos and his
army and this will be just like a scene
from the comics in the Infinity Gauntlet
saga and this will take place on a
distant planet not earth I also think
that by the end of the movie we're going
to see Thor wheeled mule near again and
hopefully at some point in time captain
wielding Mjolnir or storm breaker and of
course captain yelling Avengers Assemble
I do think that there's going to be a
second villain in Avengers in game and
no I don't think it's going to be a
Galactus or any other Fox character I
really don't believe that we're going to
see any Fox character at all in Avengers
in game but I do think it could be
either King because of time travel or
the cosmic entities Thanos has severely
changed the universe and I bet you
eternity and some other cosmic entities
probably have a problem with this and I
think we may even see the summit of the
cosmic entities just like we saw in the
Infinity Gauntlet saga in the comics
where the Living Tribunal shows up for
judgment against Thanos and what he has
done and my prediction on who is going
to die I think Iron Man is going to die
I keep thinking back to what the Russo
brothers said about real consequences
and stakes yes we all loved Captain
America but what happens if he dies the
woman that he loved has already passed
away
however Tony is about to get married and
maybe Pepper Potts is about to have a
kid as well plus he has Peter who was
like a son to him it seems like Tony
Stark has more to lose than Captain
America plus we would expect Captain
America to sacrifice himself I think
back to the very first Avengers film
where we hear the cut the wire scene and
Tony says I think I just cut the
y're tony has never really been the one
to sacrifice which is exactly why I
think that that's what we're going to
see in avengers endgame so this is what
I kind of think is going to play out in
avengers endgame i know that it's
probably not right for the most part
again just because everybody has been
saying that everything that you think
you know about this movie you don't
really know which to me is fantastic i
may be right about a few things again
this was just for the fun of it but I
very much hope that I know absolutely
nothing about what I'm about to see in
Avengers end game for those of you who
have seen it already please do not spoil
it for others in the comments down below
I have been off of YouTube off of
Twitter off of Instagram for the past
couple of days I don't want any spoilers
I'll definitely upload a spoiler free
reaction and review after the movie and
if you've seen it be sure to record your
reaction and send it to me for a chance
to end up in a fan reaction video I hope
everybody gets to see Avengers end game
soon and as always thank you all so much
for watching
[Music]
[Music]
you said it cost you everything while
crying like a baby